A warm welcome here in the room and on
the screens. I'm really pleased
about the lively interest in
our event beyond natural gas
when we discussed and selected this topic together in February.
Perhaps it was
n't quite clear to us how explosive this
topic would be today
We could have guessed it and I think it
also shows at this point that
science is really concerned with the future
and is interested in
finding solutions for the future,
what these solutions might look like, and that is what
we want to discuss today on a very
interesting podium with each other, who
will be panel participants
My name is
Stefanie molthagen-schnöring and I am
the Vice President for Research and
Transfer at the HTW Berlin.
I would like to thank
the panel
participants who
came here on a Saturday afternoon
and all the spectators  and spectators
and my team with Lena Simon with
Sir Biene Mittendorf with Gisela
Hüttinger who helped make this event
possible and now
I wish you an insightful and
inspiring time and I am pleased that
I can hand over the microphone to Vivien
[applause]
a very warm welcome  Thanks, I'm
also happy that the hall is so full and there
's so much interest. I think it
's because of this important topic that we
can discuss together right away and
before it starts, I often have
a few organizational things
behind me
a small QR code that hasn't been
scanned yet is displayed right now,
you can also log in in the hall
and ask questions online,
but you can also do it later via microphone
as you know it, we will
then distribute microphones here too
But you can also enter it there at any time
and at home you will find it
very convenient and very easy if
you scroll down a little
under the video that you are currently watching
and you can then ask questions straight away
and then we will also see
our hostess  again
Professor Stefanie meuthagen
schnürring, she is sitting
right now, which you don't see, but here in the
room at an interaction desk and
she looks through the questions a bit
and I ask for your
understanding that it may be that not
all questions are answered  We're
making an effort, but maybe it'll get to
the point where we actually have so many
questions that we can't get to all of them,
then it's not meant in a bad
way and then of course I'm
not taking part in this event alone,
but I'm really happy that we
have such great guests here  and I'll
now introduce you one by one, very
briefly and to the point, and then we'll hear
more about each other.
First, I would like to ask
Ms. Katja karger to come to me, she is the
chairwoman of the German
Federation of Trade Unions in Berlin Brandenburg
and in her position she represents around
350,000 people  Union members and there
are a lot of conversations with companies
the same applause to warm up wonderfully
then we also have
Professor Dr Barbara Praetorius
Professor at the University of
Technology and Economics in Berlin her
focus is on the areas of
sustainability and climate protection and she
was also a member, among other things  in the
coal commission and also in the chairmanship
then here we have Prof dr engineer
Volker Quaschning, also a professor at
the University of Technology and
Economics in Berlin, an advocate of
renewable energies and who was also a
co-founder of the scientists for future.
The announcement was still closed  We
see that Dr Holger Lösch
wanted to come, Deputy
Managing Director of the Federal Association
of German Industry, and we would like to send him our
warmest regards. Unfortunately, he is
unable to attend today and has to take part in
an important closed meeting on the topic.
We understand that
the topic is extremely topical, and that shows
also about it and we are all the more happy that
we were able to find a replacement, a
very exciting woman and I would like to introduce
you to Nina Heine, she is the
founder of a company
called [ __ ] to power,
she will tell us straight away what it means and I can already
tell  She simply turned her interest
into a career and set up a
spin-off from the HU Berlin here,
so now I'm pretty sure
everyone is asking themselves, okay shitu Power,
what's that all about? Ms. Heine,
you might want to
start straight away  I had to shortly within when
they said that I had turned my interest into a
career
[laughter]
of course, so I had Power pursuing
the goal of turning wastewater treatment plants into power plants.
We don't
specifically deal with the
solids or faeces as such as
you know, but rather approach them  the
sewage sludge in sewage treatment plants and the
background is the following: who has to
ask the question how can we
manage to treat more wastewater worldwide
and the background here is
that currently 80 percent of global
wastewater is not treated and we
then set out to find
a solution there  to find this sludge, for
which they are also energy
producers, theoretically contains up to three times
more energy than the
treatment of the wastewater requires and so
we came to the point of saying, man,
that's great. There's a lot of
potential here that we haven't seen yet
can we win it and this
is now a process of about two
years in which we have dealt with applications and different models in a very technical, very
theoretical and now
finally practical way,
which is very
process-technical, um, and we are now
the first system that is  Now
back in the laboratory model just to
say we can't visit it yet,
but you are warmly
invited to take a look at it when it's running,
easy to implement. The target model is
a container plant that is a sewage treatment plant
and the
energy is produced in the decentralized network
The waste material sewage sludge still has to be
won,
thank you very much. You will quickly become an
energy producer. We all in this room
have already learned something about it. Why
is it a spin-off from the HU
Berlin and why not a very
simple GmbH? So at some point it will be
a very simple one  GmbH the question is,
we have a blatant
interface topic, so on the one
hand we come from water and
water is important to us and to
simply design the freshwater cycle in such a way
that we have more of the
resource worldwide and theoretically we will
have enough of it  but we are getting more and more
dirty and so we have a topic
that is water, the next topic is
Claire mud as mud is
99 percent water when you
have the mud one percent is solid
but it is waste then it is in the
waste disposal industry and that  The next
area is the energy industry
and for us the question was how do we approach
this interface topic and
at the same time have the perspective to create added value with
the best means and,
so to speak, and
at the beginning we are also involved with companies a lot,
so everyone has to  First get
to know the industry, we are all
career changers, we all
thought there has to be a solution here,
we have to tackle it and understand
who the players actually are,
we originally wanted
to do it in Italy, maybe you will understand
why we are moving away from it for now
The various
economic players were very
interested in bringing in their own
solutions and then
we said we actually need to
go to the university because only there
can we actually freely decide
what we want to do as a project with
our goal of producing more wastewater worldwide  We
can afford treatment at the
moment when we simply work on the best
scientifically theoretical and then
technically feasible solutions
and we got this freedom, if you
want it that way, through the university
and then we are for all
those who would like to start a business
There are many start-up institutes and there
are many good ideas and opportunities.
We have found allies at the HU in the innovation hub
or Humboldt Innovation
who, together
with a professor from Professor
Prochnow, who also sits at the ATB, primarily produces
energy from biomass and
supports them there  and so we have
a network of universities and
the network for us
from the laboratory to access to resources,
thank you very much,
you can probably support that
or Ms. petorius that you can at the university
or in general at the university just like that
has a freedom and
can therefore come up with good solutions. I
would say that universities are
universities and universities are, in
my experience, a place in which
a lot of good ideas are created and in
fact start-ups and then
later spin-offs and so on
take place. That's what we're going to do  I have to say that the
university at the HTW is also very, very
supportive and there are
many good examples of what
can become of it. This is one of them
and I also find it very exciting to
see that in a small format
but not that unrelevant  Formats
also make a very important contribution to the
energy transition to making progress towards
saving energy and using it where it
occurs on a decentralized level and
I think that's what we
need to talk about a lot here, not
how do you get further towards
climate neutrality, that's what it is  the
topic of our event here and
creates this through the variety of
ideas that can
come out of the
universities from other
fields of activity, there are a
variety of initiatives and creates
a common one out of this diverse pluralistic what develops there
Climate neutrality in
Germany requires a lot of
decentralized ideas, some of them big
things, but it also needs a lot of
decentralized action and
cooperation. Then you can
tell us which idea you think
is the most promising at the moment and which
is the most promising  A not
entirely unknown idea, namely
to expand renewable energies and to do it
as quickly as possible than what has happened so far,
is that it is certainly the
core and the lever for our
energy transition. It is completely clear that we can manage our energy supply with renewable energies, both on the
electricity side and on the heat side
Of course, it takes a
certain amount of effort to cover this because we are transforming the entire
system. We are
in a
huge transformation process,
the system of energy production must be
changed, the
network structures, i.e. electricity networks but also
something like heating networks and the like,
have to be adapted  There's a lot to
do but the ideas are there. It's always
the question of whether we can achieve this
transformation step by step and there
are certainly
a lot of different ideas
required. Something like
storage technologies are also
required and something that is very,
very forgotten and in my
opinion also one  very very good idea
is because you asked for ideas is
energy efficiency on the one hand and
combined with a so-called
load management that means we have
our classic energy supply idea
is that it's a bit like
a water water flow so you have
a big vat and then  Does it flow
to where it is needed, whether it's about
the energy world, it has
often been interpreted that way so far and
actually it is now a
mixture, it comes from above,
but every board also becomes
its own fountain of energy, so to speak, or can
contribute to it and that  Whole structures of
centralized and decentralized
energy supply options
are coordinated in this digital age using
the corresponding, I would say
generalized, algorithms
and then something can come of it
without just
producing more energy but also less
and at other times  So it
just fits together better
and I think that's also a very
central topic to combine the topic of
digitalization and energy efficiency
as an important building block
for the energy transition. Ms. Kager, you're
sitting
at the table with the entrepreneurs and
trying to find solutions  to find what
these companies are also worried about,
is this digitalization
something that companies have been worrying about for a long time
or is it just now
on the rise?
Well, we've just gotten a good keyword,
namely the whole topic of
major transformation
that we as unions have
definitely been talking about  We've had it on the agenda for ten years
because it's not new,
we've actually been transforming continuously since the 70s,
but nevertheless we've had
the big change for 15 years now, which of course
goes hand in hand with digitalization, but it
's now become so multidimensional
Because with Corona, with the current
energy crises, with the supply chains,
we no
longer have the crises one after the other, so to speak, we have
them one after the other. There are of course
a lot of reasons to take a closer look at
what is actually happening and,
as always, there is no general
answer  such a question but it
is also handled very differently in the companies,
some are at the
very forefront and have also looked in good time at
how we can get
our kind of independence, whether it's
power supply, whether it's supply chains
or something similar, a lot of them but
also not and that  At the moment,
of course, is the
very worrying situation
that we have in the companies in the
companies that our
colleagues have because in many
places they don't really know at the moment that
we can actually manage everything
under the conditions
that we have been doing since the summer
On the one hand,
everything has to be done to ensure that we
get relief packages that are now
coming and that are being
rolled out very broadly, where the
companies, the people, the
employees, but also the
population with their rents and
their additional costs are really one  Experience
relief and at the same time
we can already see that the last
government was very slow on the brakes
when it came to exactly this climate neutrality, the
WE attitude towards a
socio-ecological transformation, they
completely missed that and here
we are now. I think Harbeck
actually had to start with a lot of wolf
Now let's see how he gets through it, of
course it's an extremely
difficult situation now, but we've
really lost years there,
but now we realize that companies
are trying everything they can to find alternative energies because of the cost pressure,
but we  Of course, it's
hydrogen, whether it's methane, whatever
you can capture it with, it's
not a snap and that's
our dilemma at the moment, but with
companies it's the case that they
first tell us it's important that we
get energy and  Then the
focus is on the fact that it is affordable, that
it should be climate neutral or
can we only achieve that if this
climate neutrality is also cheap?
Well, I'm not the
business association,
but I speak for the
employees and that's honestly what it's all
about  What worries me the most is,
um, because the companies have
always been very happy to do this, that
they get their returns from the companies
and now if that no longer
works then simply closing the stores
is a consequence that does
n't have to happen because  You do
n't have to squeeze 20 percent returns out of a
company, but
in crisis situations like this you can
certainly get by with three to five
percent returns, yes, but that
's a debate that is of course being
conducted internally, but of
course we have the
situation that the companies are
well prepared for  look at
what is sustainable I know
from the steel industry, for example, we
have an Eco Stahl next door in Frankfurt,
the big topic is how can they
cover their enormous energy budget and
of course look at what
really makes sense in the future and
every reasonably smart company
now knows that  in which
nuclear power somehow no longer has to be
invested in, this is
a dead horse, this is now a
transitional regulation to
cover these uncertainties, but it's
about using things and converting the entire
company to what
is sustainable, and that is wind
and sun  On the one hand,
of course, for the large
industrial processes in particular, we need
energy that has a completely different punch
and we then have to
really run with hydrogen and the like
so that we
can really get it done, but that's still a
long way off  away now we have just
heard about the Wumms we have also
heard about the Doppelwumms a few days ago
a few weeks ago what would you advise,
Mr Quaschning, which horse
should everyone bet on now what would you
like to advance which form of energy the
horses are of course the Wumms
We also have to make it clear to ourselves again
that the 200 billion euros that were burned
were not exactly there, so there is a
huge pile of money with tax money
that we are currently
burning because we have
n't made the right decisions in the last ten years
and that  We have to
make it very clear again that
all the support or other people who
do something are not
sustainable investments, but that we are
now really burning
money. We have to
do that because otherwise companies and
people would be overwhelmed, but that's why
we should  Maybe learn from this crisis
because even rich Germany
won't be able to afford to burn money in the long run
and that's why
we have to make sure that we really
set the right course and we're currently having
the climate conference in
Egypt, which is starting and yes, it's
actually already now  Greta
Thunberg has already said she's
not going there because that was
just blah again, it's going to be that we're
not setting the right course here and
just last year we had
another report from the Advisory Council
on Environmental Issues. Germany
is Parisian  In order to comply with the climate protection agreement,
we
actually have to become completely climate-neutral in the mid-2030s, which
means that it hasn't
reached politicians at all. We
now have a verdict from the
Council of Experts, which is
also supposed to advise the federal government on climate issues, and
says that it can't
even be achieved  Meeting the 2045 target
actually shows that
even though we are in the crisis, the
whole environmental policy is still not going in
the right direction and that's why
I think we just have to
be honest with ourselves and two
things: first of all, politics, politics
has to  Set framework conditions but
the population also has to accept
that we will change if we
argue about every wind turbine for ten years
and we won't get there here in Germany,
so that means we have to
see that we
expand renewable energies, that means we have to reduce
the number of wind turbines here  In
Germany, the
performance here is tripling significantly. We have to
see that we expand solar energy.
We're talking about a factor of six
to ten about what we have to increase here
and if possible in 15 years,
that means we
really have to take a step back now and keep it up  If
we need 150 years for
climate neutrality, we simply do
n't have that anymore and that's why
we have to see that we do something differently. I still see
everyone saying, well, now we'll get
the 200 billion euros and then
everything will be fine again and then we'll have it again
That's the old system and that won't
happen, that means if we
continue like this the climate crisis will
overwhelm us and then 200
billion will no longer be enough and that's
why and I miss that a
bit in this crisis that we're
just really saying now  We're
now talking about what we're doing
and this discussion isn't taking place.
We're now talking about mashed potatoes and
superglue, but not about
any solutions on how we
can get out of the climate crisis. Nothing at all from the opposition from
the tabloid media,
but there are somehow shitstorms
about some climate activists  but there is
still a total refusal when it
comes to climate and energy policy
and in this dilemma we have to get
out of it, so now I have three
like now I have
heard three groups of people who you just
criticized, they said the
politicians have to do something then
the population has to  do something different
and then the media has to
do it differently too. Now I'll ask
back in a very provocative way, what does
science have to do differently? We're
already trying to do something different. We
founded Scientist for Future in 2019. I think we have to do that
too  of course we
haven't been able to communicate
the drama
of the climate crisis and the solutions to a sufficient extent over the last 30 years,
so science has
of course developed the solutions, they
are there, so people are still
asking outside now, well, what are you doing?  Because
if the sun doesn't shine at night then
it's yes, we've already
noticed that somehow this happens in
science. The solution for it has been
developed, but it's annoying
me now because it's always the
same questions that I've been seeing for 20 years
Of course, there are always
interest groups from outside who
discredit it, but science has
simply not managed
to really communicate the solutions that exist in such a way
that everyone out here
can understand them. That's where
we want to touch our own noses,
I think  I've already seen a big
change. I've been
there for a long time. 20 years ago, I'm not saying it was
n't chic
if you somehow expressed yourself to the gray media
or somehow did a
newspaper interview. You had to
do a review journal paper like that  Then
somewhere in a Springer magazine in
the library everyone was always
very proud, but that just didn't
help us and I think that we
're now like that. It's no longer the case
that our colleagues
turn up their noses when you go somewhere
does an interview on television or something like that,
but everyone says okay,
we have to go this way and we have
a very large group with
scientists for future and
we don't know that's enough, but I think
we have to go this way and we
have to see that  that
science is not just something
aloof but that it
simply sees itself as part of the
transformation movement and
not only develops the solution but
also obviously it is necessary for it to be
communicated, one always
thought that
journalists would do it or so on  It's
their task but if the task is
not carried out sufficiently there then
science has to do it. Now
I'm just wondering whether you, Ms. Kager,
are satisfied with it. If you now think about your
union members, will
this answer help you or do
you think no, science should do it  But
actually, I can do more than
explain,
I'm a big believer in the fact that
everyone in this society
has their job, they just have to do it properly,
which means it's not my place at all
because I'm not a
scientist
to tell science whether that's the case
I think it's doing enough or not enough, I think
science can judge for itself quite well whether I've noticed it so far,
but I'm very sure that we
have to look very closely at each other, like a piece of a puzzle, so to speak,
who can do something else and that's where we have
it  It also took the unions
a few years to understand
that ecological issues are also our
issue
because, as my colleague once
said, there are no jobs on a dead planet, which
means we have to
open ourselves up to it and learn what that
actually means to
us  It also affects a lot of people and that's what
happened, so
those who sat on the so-called
coal commission know what
happened, so that was
incredibly painful but very
instructive for everyone and so I believe
or am convinced that if we
all do our part  do and if we
really keep the premise of
social-ecological transformation in
mind as a common thread then
we have a chance of getting it done with
all the looming challenges,
stress over time, political
headwind that we have but it
is also at the same time and there we see
We in many companies that have started in the
right direction there
is really a lot of
innovation potential there is a lot of
economic power if we
go this way and of course we have to
make sure that
at this point the
political parties the government
really the  good framework conditions
so that people and
companies can move well along this path
and that we take everyone with us because
what can't happen to us is that
we leave behind people who then do
n't understand it and reject it because then
we'll have these 10,000 AFD [ __ ]
on our hands  the street, yes, so
I think that's something that we have to look at very closely together,
but in my opinion a lot has happened in the
last ten years
that
meshes well with each other. I would really
like to have a few ideas at the end of the event
in the room so that everyone
who is here and who has
connected online has the feeling okay,
now I know a bit about how we
can approach this future, how we
can become independent and how we
can become climate neutral, but I would like to
take the opportunity for a moment because
they  have just been addressed directly, in
principle you can chat a bit about what it
was like in the coal commission and second question
would you like to be in the
gas commission right now
so
last question to answer that briefly
I think that I have
spoken to people who are there  Collaboration
has obviously
been even more concentrated and more intensive
and it is extremely important to have great
respect for what has been achieved
in a very short space of time and I believe
that the suggestions that have
come up are definitely worth discussing,
they are always
short-term
short-term decisions under
pressure and always under difficult
conditions and I have a lot of
respect for that as far as the coal commission is concerned,
out of the box,
I think that would be going beyond the scope here, but I would
like to support
what Ms. Kager said again, that's just how
it was  Just as much a
process of discovery and we are
also in order to build on what
Volker quaschning said, we are
in the situation that we
know incredibly well and we have it, maybe
we missed it, but there were
also opposing forces that presented it as positive images
to bring the road and if I
can say one thing in summary about
the discourse in the coal commission,
it was precisely that we really acquired a
lot of knowledge from each other and
understanding the other
side, so the gift of completely
different interests that
met each other and  but we also
know a lot about what a future
can look like and I think that's what
we need overall and
have to do much more strongly,
also in the sense of even better
science communication, that we
don't just say we know that it's possible,
but also  that we also convey
that an energy supply
based on renewable energies and
energy efficiency can definitely work,
that there is, that is completely clear,
but
it is still the case that there are jobs
in the world because of the planet  Then it
's not dead
and maybe not just maybe
but probably even
better quality jobs but
that's a discussion that
maybe needs to be had separately. What do
you know, what
helps companies now that say I
really have a problem here, I'm
creative in terms of energy  and I don't know how
I'm going to get out of here. Are there
any solutions that
work in the short term or are there
long-term solutions that we're all
working on? I think that's one.
The situation is different. The
energy-intensive companies are
the companies that are  We've been
dealing with the issue for much, much longer, yes,
because they have high energy costs, yes,
I'll say on average in the
German economy, it
probably no longer applies now, but it was
until before the Ukraine crisis, the war,
that one could say  that
the energy costs make up around two
percent of the total production costs, there
are much more
important factors that you
deal with in many, many
smaller companies or
services and so on, but in
energy-intensive companies this has
of course been an issue for much longer
because they  simply have much higher
proportions of costs based on
energy, which means that they
started looking at efficiency with
new production options very early on
and they are definitely
aware of the science that
we are getting a climate problem
and that is  If you do
n't react to it, it may become
difficult for the energy-intensive industry,
so that means they have also
started to develop processes, the
technologies and, in short, the
technologies are basically there and are also
known, they need hydrogen, that is, in
some cases they need
hydrogen  Sometimes it's a
little different, but they are well
known. Like
many
investments, they are initially expensive,
which means we have to
create bridges so that the
investment cycles can now be used.
Yes, you build large
systems that last 20
In any case, you should spend 30 years now if
you make such investments, they have to
be aligned with this new world
and these are the processes that
are currently being discussed as to how you
can achieve this. There are
technical terms like Carmen Contracts
for Difference and so on  So there
are so many different procedures, how you
can somehow come together
between industry and politics to
promote this. In the short term, of course, we now have
the counterproductive thing we are
currently experiencing, namely that people are trying to
turn back the use of natural gas and
burn more oil in some
power plants or on coal
of course that's
where I say in comeback back to
coal that really can't
be the way to go, so in that respect you
also have to differentiate a lot. The companies
are preparing for it, so I was also
really surprised at some of the
dynamics there  and ideas are there
and now we have this crunch crisis in the short term
and what do you think
of ideas like those from Ms. Heine
[music]
for the industry for the
energy-intensive industry, I do
n't know, that's not enough, it
probably won't be enough, no, it is  It's also
right that you then
think about which
sections you
need hydrogen for, so like this
future one, there's also a hype that's
somehow floating around, a big
myth that we're doing everything with
hydrogen now, even if you
talk to automobile friends
Everyone says yes, electric vehicles are great, but ca
n't it be better with
synthetic fuels and
hydrogen? I say it's too expensive,
much too expensive, it will never
be cheap, but in industry you need
it and you have to
think carefully about how  you produce it where you
produce it, but that might
require an engineer, well,
but I think what's important is what
I meant by the common
puzzle, that exactly such solutions
are important for the little ones and
local supplies - that's the
whole topic of power  heat coupling food is
more of a local issue we have to
get to the point where we
supply our neighborhoods with energy differently than
always with the big hit so that we
have really very coordinated different systems next to each other that then mesh well with each other
but that's
exactly what we would have  should have started ten years ago
and what
now simply has to happen faster, so
it is important for us at this
point that we take a closer look,
especially when we are now investing more heavily with the new
energies, that
we pay close attention to what is
happening  what kind of companies they are,
how they are managed and how the
employees are taken along. We
have a lot of experience in
Brandenburg
with the entire solar industry, where
100,000
jobs were created in a very short time and then
cut back just as quickly. That does
n't necessarily make things any better
and now we have
dependence on China when it
comes to this entire solar industry, so that was
n't really smart, yes, and we have a
similar issue with wind energy. We
lost 40,000 jobs in the north within three and four years
because the last government had this whole
energy levy  Somehow everything
has changed, the funding has stopped and so on
and so forth and for us it is
important when we invest in these new
technologies in the new
companies, invest in the new energy,
we always have to
look at what the conditions are like there  If there are
works councils, the employees have
a say because that's what comes
down the drain in most cases,
then I have a nice ecological
company but the work is below
the minimum wage, and then
we have exactly this debate that is
not part of the population  comes along in
this process of change because they are
paying the bill for it, yes, and
I think we have to take a much closer
look at what is, so to speak, how do
we actually want to
live and work together in the future? This is not
just a question of we need an
alternative  Energy we need a
different kind of how do we generate
heat flow together and all the
rest but also what kind of
society do we want to live in? It has
broken down so much in recent years into so many
individualists and special interests
that it is becoming incredibly difficult to do what is
actually happening  They're already
in the middle of it all, it's no longer up
to us, yes, but we can't manage that
with particular interests anymore
and so to speak, to make a
plan for society as a whole means how can we somehow achieve
this
together? We
hardly dare to do that these days
describe it because with the last
government the word solid was
somehow trampled to death in
all sorts of
occasions, so to speak, if you will,
but that's actually what it's all
about, that we connect with each other differently
and
understand each other differently anyway  he has just
mentioned it once, there is applause,
we would like to
have an engineer's opinion on this, Mr
Quaschning, what are you thinking when you
listen to this, it is very exciting, I
come from renewable energies and
we are currently
having this job cut  Of course, we were
also very concerned then, so
2008 19 those were the boom years of
photovoltaics then 11 12 13 it was
turned back again. I had a
really good graduate
with us who changed jobs four times a year,
not because he always  was
thrown out and that was every
company where he started
went bankrupt in the solar sector and
you just have to say that the
jobs haven't gone away, they are
now in China so you have to
say that again that wasn't
particularly clever we have  continued to
rely on cheap gas and
legal certainty now simply
means that what we see now in the
energy crisis are still the mistakes
of the last 10 20 years and those
responsible are still
distracting and not discussing a solution but I do
n't want to repeat myself now  What
I said before, maybe
we just have to look at the question about hydrogen
again as engineers, or what
Barbara Petrius said now,
we just have to look at the prices again
because we now have a
bit of a story, well  somehow
we do everything with natural gas and
we can do that well, it's now a
bit expensive, we're doing that now with
the gas price brake and then comes the
green hydrogen and everything is good
and hydrogen green hydrogen will
have a lot of importance but
hydrogen is just that  Champagne of the
energy transition and champagne has an
importance on the diet but
not as a staple food, yes, and
we just have to make that clear to people,
so the natural gas will just
be really expensive, so the prices
we have today, the green gas, the green
hydrogen, the prices we have  Today we will
see with natural gas that we will
have with hydrogen, only without
a gas price brake and we have to see that
and that's why we should use the gas or
the synthetic ones, I hope, exactly
where we don't have a plan B
but for all other things, i.e.
for heating  Driving a car or
something like that, there are simply much better,
more efficient technologies and that's why
we also have to talk about things like
banning
combustion engines, for example, the EU now wants that
in 2035 and the Germans
now want to have some kind of exception
rules again, now I can just do that  Let's do the
math and that just annoys me in
a discussion like this, so the
last combustion car is supposed to come onto the road in 2035 to
be there again, it lasts an
average of 20 years, that means
this combustion car is on
the way by 2055 but Germany wants to go by 2045
Let's be 03, that doesn't work, yes,
and there are two solutions: either
we force everyone to use the expensive
e-fuels, 4 to 5 euros a liter of fuel,
I'm thrilled, as are
the poor nurses who
always drive their cars now  It has to be
pulled all the time so that we
don't have to change how it's supposed to
handle it or we'll scrap
all the cars in 2045,
but that will be relatively expensive for both the state and
the population and
we actually have to discuss it in Germany in
To stop using combustion engines simply because of
this consideration that others do
n't match the promises we make in terms of
climate protection, the
same is true with gas, so if
you hurry up now you'll get funding from KfW this year
for the installation of a
new gas heater  So that's
why there are so many absurdities that
we have here in Germany and we have
to put an end to them and we have to have an
honest discussion and then not
about e-fuels and we will now be able
to build Porsches and then
somehow some
wind power will come from Chile  I've done the calculations so
maybe I'll finish this again with
these absurdities. The FDP would
like to have e-fuels, that's why we can continue to
buy combustion engines. Efuels are
made from hydrogen, so first
I make hydrogen from wind power,
then I can make petrol out of it and
cars can only drive with it  If we want to refuel the
entire car fleet in Germany with
Lindner wanted to do that in Chile
with e-fuels from Chile,
we would need seven times as much electricity
as Schiele currently
uses in total in his own country, and that wo
n't happen in ten years
work and these are all not
locks, all excuses in principle
so that we don't have to change today
and with these excuses there has to
be a lock and we know the
technologies we also know and we
can simply say with the rule of three that
most things work or do
n't work  efuels won't
work. Hydrogen in the heating
at home will be very expensive, so it wo
n't work for most people
and then we just have to leave the things
that we already know won't
work and
we don't do that in Germany, we just do
that  We'll keep doing it and hope
that in the end we'll start again with
a big wallet if things
go wrong and save everyone and that won't
work in the long run. We've now
mentioned speed, which is what's most important
and if you think about it
like that  If you ask around a bit,
you'll always hear that the
approval process generally takes a long time
and that it's a bit of
a problem that delays a lot of things.
Now I wanted to ask questions from
Ms. Heine's practice, what kind of
experiences have you had?
Oh yes,
that's our experience with it
Approval and entire processes are
always accompanied by a lot of new requirements,
but somehow people forget to abolish the old ones
and so we end up in
situations where, firstly, many
others don't even know what
needs to be done and some of them are
so high that it is
It's extremely difficult for startups to get into this at all, but
on the other hand, there are
simply regulations that
obviously play into our hands when it comes to
reclaiming certain things or simply
focusing more on renewable energies and
actually looking at the diversity
of potential renewables
Energy resources in Germany
to employ locally on the site
it works well but try to
rent a laboratory in Berlin currently so if you have
one say yes I was just about to
say maybe there is
someone here with a laboratory the
problem would have been solved okay so the
permit problem  Exactly,
we have just
written a very long report for our own system about
what can happen because something cannot
happen and
it would probably be easiest
if we all just use
our prototype and I mean it is
a prototype it is  nothing great,
first go to the TÜV or to Dekra and
then have a stamp put on it, but
if you try to
implement something as quickly as possible and put it into practice
then maybe one or
two of the
regulations are a bit tight when it
comes to progress and speed,
okay, so we  The question about the
laboratory is in the frame
and Ms. Moll is now waving at the
back. Days are busy with other questions. There
is also another one in the room at the front. We'll get
to that in a moment. I just wanted to
hear what's going on online, thank you
There's a lot going on, the rules are being discussed,
which is why I just wanted to
jump in here for a moment.
Someone would like to chat, Mr. Colleague. You
have a five-minute master plan, so I'm against it now because if he
were to say it now, then we would
lose it  Next week it will
probably be more with us at the
university but in some
other position, so
maybe not the 5 minute
master plan, but the question that
concerns a lot of people in the chat here is the
question of what specifically, so we've
often talked about what's going on
not what objectives do we have
perhaps in the distance or in the
medium term, but what are the
other really concrete things that
can be done that are technically
possible, that are possible in terms of regulation
and that will take us one step
further? These are
two things we know what
we are
I've already said that I no longer need or want to have a
combustion car, these are oil and
gas heaters and then you just have to
put an end to it at some point and do it as quickly as possible,
ideally from next year.
The federal government has already banned
heating for two thirds, so it's the same again
a classic compromise but better
than nothing at all, so something is happening in the
transport sector, nothing is happening because
Mr. Wissing refuses
to do his homework, so of
course we have to make sure that we
set the course and don't create more and more
contaminated sites, i.e. every
combustion car  What we are
putting on the road now will become a problem in 15
years. Every gas heater
we install now will become a
problem for climate protection in 10-15 years and that's
why we have to end it as quickly as
possible. So that's
not a problem for now  make more mistakes,
that's first of all I think the
most important thing and then there are
things like no regret measures where
we know what we need, so
with renewables so as I
said, electricity from [ __ ] or something like that is
also good but it will be  Essentially
solar and wind energy are not so that
means there are other
renewables but the niche technologies
they will perhaps be
able to cover a total of 20 percent. The other 80%
comes from sun and wind simply
because of potential considerations and that
means we actually have to do that
Sun and wind can be built as quickly as possible
and if we know that we need
between six and ten years for
wind farms today, then we also know
that we won't get there and then
you have to think about
it
took a year or two
then we just have to get back there as quickly as
possible why is it taking
so long and that's the next one
so we had
the energy transition in various countries in the 2010s which had some
players in the market  The
traditional energy companies don't like it and they
have
taken various measures against it in different countries.
In Spain they completely banned the expansion of
solar energy for a few years.
That was
n't done in Germany and the German way is
then simple, they make very, very
complicated laws so that  In the end, it's
somehow no longer possible to
do that and
we now have these complicated laws and actually
the big energy companies don't even want them anymore.
I found that somehow
interesting, so I recently
complained to RWE that it was so difficult
to build wind turbines  Well, you're
not entirely innocent about it, it's so
difficult and that means
we actually have to make sure that we can
achieve this speed,
so clear out the laws so that we can actually
achieve the speed, so this
is a huge catastrophe, especially in the wind sector, with
sufficient solar
wind energy plus storage  of course
build and what we no longer
want to have, i.e. stop combustion cars and
heating systems as soon as possible
and if we take these measures
we will get very far, there are
many others but then
we won't be able to do that in three or five minutes
but there are  It's the
universities and the companies that have to
develop the solution and implement it. Thank you very
much. I would like to
remain a bit interactive because this is
a topic that concerns us all and I
've already noticed that there are also
requests to speak here. We already have that  Micro
in use here in the front row would be
someone who would like to ask a question,
thank you, hello, my name is Tina semik, I'm
interested in this, so the key word is [ __ ]
to gold. As far as
I know,
Denmark produces 30 percent of its
energy from
bio-biokraft Bio who can produce the biogas
we don't do that too, is that
feasible or how do we estimate the potential
and is it possible to achieve that
in Germany?
So with biomass
the potential is always limited so
the biomass has a certain
degree of efficiency so that means we have we
practically take sunlight that
is converted into into  Biomass and if
you just look at the
efficiency of plants,
it is well
below one percent, which means
less than one percent of sunlight
is then converted into biomass, a
solar cell is simply 20%.  That
means if you do this with photovoltaics
then we get 30-40 times as much out of the same
area as if I were to grow
organic corn and that
simply ensures that the amount of
bio fuel or material that we
can use in Germany is limited
So depending on the potential study,
you get between 10-15 maximum 20 percent of what
we can do with biomass.
We're already pretty close to it today
because we already have a relatively large amount of use
and that can't be expanded as much anymore
because we've populated it  There are
other countries like Finland, for example.
I think Finland
now has 30% biomass, but of
course they have a lot more
land and forest per inhabitant than we do in
Germany. In our country, it's just very
limited,
well, and there is always biomass
also the problem or at least the
danger of monoculture you need
incredible amounts of corn has a
relatively good energy throughput but that
means you really have endless
fields with mostly that's what
even if you think about ecology
is like that and that  is always the debate
that we have in many places, yes, that
when we have a good idea,
as always, we have to look closely at it,
impact assessment, yes, that
usually leads to something else in some way
and that's
why you have to adjust it very carefully
and is
actually only a limited solution for
all kinds of residues, but extremely clever, yes,
in this case, whether these
are our human residues or
simply biogenic residues in every producing
industry, there is always
potential to use them appropriately. That's what they do
Most
companies too, so that's the
crazy thing we have in the current
situation, that the big
companies are not our issue,
but where it's only now getting to the point is
with the small and medium-sized ones, those are
the craft businesses, some of whom are
now suddenly faced with the costs  are
saying crap and they don't
have the financial background themselves and to
say now I'm going to take five
steps forward and see how
he gives star solutions that they
can do it in all possible
variants, it's natural at the moment
because it  Then it becomes so detailed and
fragmented exactly what
slows things down.
I would like to add that this is because the question
has been asked about what we need now. Of course, we
also ultimately need a
training initiative. Yes, we need to do it much
faster and much more,
perhaps we do too  At our
universities, but overall in
the economy, we
train people who can implement this energy transition, we can
do it with craftsmanship. There is
also a huge
shortage at the moment. There is certainly
something similar like
further training issues, i.e. the people
who are now trained  than as a
heating fitter and fitter, it's
more like they
all have to
learn new techniques now, so to speak. There are bottlenecks everywhere, no matter
who you talk to,
so to speak, to
what extent is this already the
know-how house and what the world of tomorrow
could look like  What options are there?
I do
n't want to offend anyone. I think a
lot of people are doing excellent work there,
but in any case there is a
clear lack of skilled workers and
I think that's a
task for us as a university to
help achieve that  you are trained and
things are implemented in the way
I can then
adapt exactly, we have to
agree, of course, that now we are
sitting at the same table with the union and
of course we are thinking about job transformation,
so we know that we are
somewhere in between  depending on how quickly we
make the energy transition, we need between 300,000 and
up to a million new jobs, on
the other hand, 500,000 will be lost at least once,
so it's very, very
exciting. We published my study in 2016 where
we discussed 100% renewable
energies, including in
transport and then  Three days
later, I got an email from the
Mineral Oil Industry Association where
we somehow see the future of
lubricants in Germany. Of
course, you can only do that when I
have electric cars, the classic
oil change will no longer be necessary, there will be 100,000
jobs attached to it, you just have to
Let's look at it this way, that means
of course we have a transformation on the
other hand, on the other hand we will
have more jobs overall than we have, but
people will have to
do something else and that we can
manage it, that of course there will be
no one left behind  There are people who
then end up on the streets again, that
we take all the people with us, that we
qualify them in a timely manner, and above all, that we
qualify these quantities in a timely manner, that is an enormous
challenge in politics, we talk
a bit like that, yes, you have to use a
keyword like that about the shortage of skilled workers  But
solutions aren't being discussed here yet,
that's not true, that's really
true. In fact, you have
a whole battery so because the topic
has been around for ten years now, so to speak, the
issue of skilled workers has
come to us and we're talking to
politicians  the employment agency and so
on and so forth, an example is that
in Brandenburg, for example,
we have a fairly sophisticated
skilled workers strategy that
also includes areas such as how can we achieve
systematic further training
so that we
have a round table with
the mayor in Berlin  In order to
make these climate-related professions strong, in order to
find ways and means, how can
we get the young people to the point where they
no longer
want to become hairdressers and car mechanics, but
actually want to become a
very unusual, sustainable
craft profession that
we have at the federal level
The big
skilled workers strategy has just come out these days. We
now have
a Prime Minister's Conference in the
East in the next few weeks that will take care of exactly how
we get the potential of the
employees transformed. Yes, how do we achieve
exactly that, so to speak, the
matching, that's what it is  not
even done like that, yes, because I know the
experience I have had in Hamburg in
the last few years. People
who work at the shipyard
have been shipyard workers for 30 years, become
unemployed and what they are offered
is to become a kindergarten teacher, but that
is not the case  It's so easy
to teach your colleagues that it's an
exciting job, but it's
not for everyone, which is what
transformation means
taking a closer look and that's the
great thing we've achieved with the coal commission
down in Lusatia
Yes, and I think we really do
n't pay enough attention to the fact that this
revierwende that's currently going on down there
is exactly that. You're right in the middle of
this process of change. Yes, Lausitz is
a cool region. It's really happening to the
people, they have money in their
blood, so to speak  To say you have to get out of there
and it's a different time now, so to speak,
you have to have other jobs is
what is really painfully
happening right now but what is working very excitingly in
many places,
we have the railway
down there now, they have it there  The
repair shop has now opened, which means that
from the apprenticeship the people are being trained bit by bit
in a very individually
tailored further training course to become railway
employees. That has
of course slowed down a bit now
because suddenly coal is popular again,
but that doesn't mean that and that's
what interests me  It's also very, very reassuring
that all our
colleagues down in Lusatia say we do
n't want to go back to coal anymore.
We've now gone down this path.
The only thing we want is that
we don't have to put the potatoes out again
Potatoes back out of the
potatoes the way is now clear we're
getting out down there
and we've got an opportunity
to really develop and
preserve our colleagues in good work, so to speak, and that works
and it's there in every nook and cranny
that is  Well, the topic of skilled workers is
really something that we are constantly discussing in all
areas because it is now
slowly becoming a problem among smaller companies
and this of course also includes the fact that
decent working conditions are the be-all and end-all
if you have to look for workers
you pay them decently and
have good conditions and I have to
do my job for a moment and
intervene as a moderator because there
are already a lot of questions and you
have just noticed that it is worth
asking a question and you get
a lot of answers  It's great and
now we have a few questions exactly
once in the last row. I
actually just wanted to address one thing
that is often ignored in such rounds and
also by politicians
and that is the topic of growth.
It is now pretty clear that
we  Climate neutrality will only be achieved
if the global north
manages to move away from economic growth. Just to give you a number,
if an economy grows at 1.5%
then it will double every 50
years, that is, if we become twice as
efficient as we are today
we use exactly the same amount of resources
as we do today and we will use so
much aluminum cobalt rare earths
to create this transformation
that it is simply not possible
and I would just like to
hear your opinion on it, it is simply
an unpleasant topic which of course comes
from the  Politics is avoided, which in
my opinion
needs to be addressed because this
compound effect of the percentage over
time is simply so strong that we will
then
have a huge problem, so your question
is whether you will agree to it, yes,
yes  Positions I'm happy
to say something about that, of course they're right
if they look purely and exclusively at
material growth,
quantitative growth in material
terms and the discussion is
of course it's actually I'm
also right the discussion is avoided
because our
economic system, so to speak, is made up of all sorts of things
Reasons based on this,
I say, but there are certainly
debates about the extent to which one can arrive at a
qualitative assessment of I wo
n't even say the word growth, I'm
trying to avoid a
qualitative assessment of the economy and
economic activity and
then one can also say yes  It
actually concludes a little
differently from what you said, that you
pay work in the way that it
represents a value to society and,
for example, you don't try to
squeeze out as much as possible, but
rather pay social professions properly, for
example if you paid all of these
social professions the way
they actually do  who are to be estimated then
we would have an enormous formal
economic growth only as that would be
reflected in the gross domestic product in a positive way without
any more material having been used in any way,
so there are already thoughts that
go in that direction, the other is
actually the question of how
We can continue to consume as we have
done so far and to what extent are
we satisfied with it and is that
actually the right prosperity model
that we have here grow grow that
can't work the planetary
boundaries have become noticeable and are
becoming more and more noticeable that is
absolutely right and it's
actually something I can only
support you on the highest level,
so to speak, to think
about how we
evaluate our lives differently than now
in purely monetary or material
terms, but of course that's also
a gradual thing  Process in some
places you notice a little bit. I do
n't want to just talk about it in a negative way, but
if you look at, for example, how
much value the next
generation, i.e. the students,
students like we get to know,
how much value they place on
having their own car  or something like that is
clearly noticeable and can also be
read in the statistics in the empirical evidence that
the need for this status symbol is
decreasing significantly, which is why, for example,
the automotive industry is thinking about how
they can somehow
serve the need for mobility differently
or something like that  Something
also changes that you no longer have to have,
but maybe that's only at one point
and what's important is actually
quite clear that we have to become more efficient,
that's still not enough,
but if we don't become more efficient
then we've really
lost completely  I would say that because we then
have the situation that we would have a I would say
even if you see electrification as
a core part of the energy transition
because we would then need so much electricity that
it would be really
difficult and then the
material side of this electricity requirement
ceilings in the form of wind turbines,
aluminum and so on, there are also many
questions that are open, also composites
and so then we get into new
problems that we
don't actually want to have, that we want to
avoid from the start.
Maybe one
more comment  The additional problem we
have here is that we have so far had
the promise of growth if we just
grow then everyone will be better off,
but what we are actually
experiencing in society is
that the gap in the situation
is widening and I think that is
also a task  which one can
only say has been neglected for a long time
and where it
now urgently has to be the case
simply through
a different distribution of what we
have, some would also get out of
Osnabrück. Gentlemen's work and
life situations
Seen other questions
right there in front there is one and then
behind it
okay thank you so there is
actually an expert sitting here not an academic
Heating Plumbing here in Berlin-Kreuzberg
I am also two memory master
of Friesheim Kreuzberg
existing buildings for example that is
my question what do we do with it?
Just the day before yesterday we put a building into
operation again that
had no heating for six months. I was
really happy that I still got gas heating. There's
actually
going to be a hybrid solution in there. We'll get
a heat pump at some point. I do
n't want to go into too much detail about
that  then in a
further step,
what happens later when we
use hydrogen, i.e.
hydrogen that is based on how much
rent-versus in existing materials in
parts of the system that we have already installed?
We can't convert everything,
especially not existing buildings and for
training, I am a wonderful topic
Fully included five trainees from
five different nations from
all over the world
1040 specialist book pages yes,
I'll say someone who
was born here in Germany and was in
a German school here
has extreme difficulties, so as I said,
we almost have  Engineering knowledge in it
we now come from a
completely normal I would say heating via
fire
via thermodynamics or sat in
that simply means physics plays
a role that the young people do
n't have at all, yes we
only see crashes crashes crashes crashes
in the  Training is a
big topic for us, especially internally.
Nothing is happening, not even from the
Conference of Ministers of Education and Cultural Affairs. We
have 350 hours of school hours more
now over three and a half years.
We can forget about them, but the young people are losing
their share of training in the
company  then at 1 p.m. and
10 minutes go home in the
schools because there are
10 vocational school teachers
missing here in Berlin, getting them is a
catastrophe, so all of that, yes, it's so
huge and so complex, that's why I'm
sorry, I hear  I'm happy to be open to solutions.
They have great stories
and also great ideas about how to use their
technologies, but that also has to
be lived and that has to
be implemented and that's why thank you very much
for your question. They basically
asked two questions, once the question of
what to do  We are now dealing with the
existing building and the second question
was how do we get young people to
get involved who wants a good
existing building? The
technical solution is clear, so most of what
you have to do in the future is really the
electric heat pump, the heat pump
is simply very efficient I can  Turning
one kilowatt hour of electricity into 3
kilowatt hours of heat and for
a long time the heat pump has had the reputation
that it
can only be done together with underfloor heating.
The
Fraunhofer Institute in Freiburg has now also carried out
studies on heat pumps in existing buildings
and there are now also
high temperatures  Heat pumps that
can be equipped in many buildings, even in old buildings, are of course there, then
we come to another technical detail. If
you have gas heating, it will
of course be a bit complicated,
especially if you
have condominiums and everyone cooks their own soup
The German one
then somehow has to get together to
install a central heat pump, but
there are technical solutions.
Gas heating, as I said, is a solution
that in the end will simply remain at the same prices
if I convert to hydrogen
that we already have today and
that's what people have to do  In the apartment you
can or want to pay
and that's why my recommendation is to
use the heat pump wherever it's technically possible. The district heating
is also easier to convert than
the existing one
and in this respect we can
maybe do it in private afterwards
So talk about it, but I'll say that the be-all and
end-all is actually to
stop installing gas heating wherever possible
and then rely on the
heat pump with the skilled workers. Yes,
that's what I always hear from the
industry, that's just
difficult at the moment  It's also not looking so good here in the
technology sector at the universities,
so we have
training places available in renewable
energies, so here in Berlin it's
still the same. Colleagues from
other universities look similar.
I was also there recently at the
roofing hand conference  They
also have problems with the next generation, so
you can see that there are problems everywhere and
we probably won't be able to cover this with German
skilled workers,
not even with the
transformation because the gap is so big,
then we have to try to
solve it through immigration  and then
we get into exactly these language problems
that you saw and that's why
I think so, I say
it's not all solved yet, so
we really have to think about
how we can
close the gaps with immigration  and
how do we then manage to integrate these
people who of course also
have a language barrier,
perhaps also to differentiate the jobs?
I don't mean that
everyone has to be able to do everything, so that you
might say in some way there is,
but then we also have to
completely  create new models and do so as
quickly as possible, so there are
still challenges to be solved, but
thank you very much for the
offer of exchange, even in retrospect.
I think that is also a solution
that will probably help.
Maybe something else about the training,
I can imagine that  If you want to say something else,
I'll try to make it
as brief as possible, although of
course it's extremely complex and you
described it quite correctly. Yes, we
have it pretty well on our list because
we have to come at it from several sides at the same time
and that's it  What's
interesting about it is, on the
one hand, we have school training where
in many places the career orientation does
n't work optimally, and in some cases it
doesn't even exist in high school. We're
currently in the process of ensuring that
high school students get career orientation
and get away from this - you
have a high school diploma  Are you going to
university? We
now have a
dropout rate of 30 and sometimes 40
percent at the universities. Yes, and at the moment we are
currently in the debate between the
different senators in Berlin.
In this case,
we're looking at how do we organize this?
Then you get an offer from
the university, which the university
does, but training is
n't a bad thing, but on the
contrary, you have a good
perspective. At this point,
the universities are reluctant to do that, but
at the same time we also have the situation where
we see that  A lot of parents did
n't grow up with the German
education system and did
n't appreciate it accordingly, some of them went
through the whole political change in the 1970s.
Finally, we're all allowed to
go to university, so we all go to
university. We have a very
bad reputation  Vocational
training which is a catastrophe because
we have the best vocational
training in the world with which
we get really, really good people into
skilled positions, which
means we have to start with the parents
who somehow convey to their children
what is your future perspective
and we  But then we also have to
start with the companies because what
we experience a lot is that there is
still a basic attitude: I make
the best selection as a company and
look for them, oh they don't exist anymore,
crap and the willingness is then very
low  To say yes, I train means
I really train them, that means
I make sure that I
take the people with me, that I also teach them
basic arithmetic, that
we can't carve out the young people,
yes they are the way they
are now  and in Berlin we have a
very diverse workforce of
possible trainees, so I
think we all have to move a lot and
exactly in this conglomerate
with the vocational schools and that
's a huge topic I was at the two
days ago  Senator Busse does
n't have the vocational school on her list at all,
that was terrible, and
I've already heard that at
the federal level there is now
an excellence initiative for the schools
and somehow for vocational
training and
the vocational schools they have
again  Forgot, yes, and that's
where we're
really
firing on all cylinders, even if that's a crooked picture,
but where you where we're really attacking like
crazy with all the options we can
and saying you have one
Huge issue if you want skilled workers
you have to be on ten construction sites at
the same time, yes, but
of course that's in political
circumstances and that's of course
always nice to say we have to now we
have to now we have to now but
political circumstances mean there is a
coalition and B  Democracy means
negotiating things in compromises, yes,
and that's sometimes not ideal
when you have the FDP in the government.
Sometimes it's not ideal because you
have the CDU without a government, yes, and then
and so things move
much faster than we do  have to get it done
but I can at least say that
we know the problem you have and we are really on it,
the chambers are also incredibly involved
so identify problems
find solutions we are also gone I
saw that there is still a question,
but I wanted to be very short  Just ask Ms. Heine
because sometimes
you don't even have to wait until
someone presents you with a solution;
it was completely different for them. They
actually approached the whole topic completely
differently when they founded the company.
I found that very interesting, maybe
you would like to  tell me again how
she came to found [ __ ] to Power,
I think I would like to briefly
go into the training because it's always a bit like that and
now we old people look at the
young people and
what did they actually learn
and I  I think that's what every
generation does to the next and it came
to me a little bit
straight away, so I would actually make us
clever and everyone,
every person can bring something, and
especially when it comes to training,
I think so
Often in Germany only
someone who has a parental home can afford training, so
that says no problem. Miracle number three
years for me because the salaries
are just so low and from a
more business perspective,
the question is how do
I finance what?  Am I implementing something and how
can we improve something and I think
we just have to go much further and
see what lies beyond the
horizon, so here is the edge of the box
and now we have to
go beyond it because the way we have done it so far
is just that  Simply nothing happens
and everyone is lying there somehow comfortably
on their couch and watching, yes, human beings are fine,
but about climate change
and the fact that we as a society but
simply as humans are still on
this planet, then we have to
move and become active and  For
us it was simply I think every person
has something that he or she
can be enthusiastic about and in my case
it was simply the topic of water. I find
water incredibly exciting.
We need water to survive at a very basic level.
It's a human right and
how does that actually happen  handled and
I actually
took the time to say I
just want to give this topic some time in terms of content and see what comes
out of it and there is water, there is
enough fresh water on this planet
in principle
and what was the distribution problem that
we have a climate crisis so there are
periods of drought  and there is heavy rain
so now it's not ideal either
you have too many people have too few
now of course we can say great
we have water here we put it in
bottles and we distribute it we have
solved the distribution problem that's how
some big corporations do it too
You can make a lot of money with it and I found
it a bit boring because you
could of course
turn it into political activation but
I'm not necessarily that politically inclined
to say yes, Germany has
the very best tap water if you
take some water from the tap in Germany  is more tested than
if they
import water in a bottle from another country and
drink it from it, what can we do that
actually brings something and then
it just takes time, so shite power definitely did
n't
come to me overnight, it's more like it is
I was involved in another
project with a lot of scientists - it
always sounds so strange -
but I started talking to people who just came from
different industries
to understand
what their problems were and what had
to do with water on the one hand
Just in your everyday life and
through another project I
got into agriculture. At
some point in agriculture there was a
farmer who looked at me about the
project we were working on at the time and
said is he serious now
that you are dealing with this project
There are so many bigger problems, for
example, I asked him what
the biggest problem is, so the
biggest problem is that there is currently a
lot of sewage sludge driving around on the highway,
so I found that really
interesting, like what is
sewage sludge and why is it driving  on the
highway and I think we have
to be more curious, we have to
deal with what is
actually happening in our country but also what is
happening in the city in the village in the
communities where we live and where can we
start things that are currently going on
because  They run like that because it
was somehow cheap and the gas has always come
from Russia, that's great, let
's now think about how
we can actually change a lot of things, even in a more
decentralized universe or area,
perhaps on a very small scale,
for ourselves, for others and
with each other  and instead of these,
what he can do and somehow well
and does that by
arousing curiosity and
thinking further and then
interlinking things with each other and then developing something in
communication and exchange and
interdisciplinarity
It works, I was standing there
now so it was okay, cool, awesome, so
now I'm going to take a
closer look at sewage sludge because I have
n't had any contact with it yet and I
just got involved in this
topic of wastewater and wastewater
is the resource that we have
everywhere  where people live so let's take a
closer look at it and then the
idea was okay if we
find a decentralized solution wherever there are
sewage treatment plants today,
getting them going again by using
the energy from themselves
always sounds like that  nice but if we
can get energy from the
biological residue from the biological
residue then we have created a lever
and we need these levers
because we live in the
capitalist system so if I
develop something that is really great but
in the end costs more energy or always
costs more effort than what
comes out of it, then no one will
buy it and then it wo
n't work either, so we need something that I
enforce and start-up area we
always say scaled and then the
idea was born and now I was standing there,
how do we do it?  Now technically and
then getting involved with it, which
people are there, who knows about it,
who can help me with it, who would like to
implement it with me and then it was
further away to understand who is interested, who
is it interesting for and
who do I want to do it with  Personally, I'm also working on it
and so for me it's a really exciting
journey and I just appeal to
people's curiosity about doing it and
trying it and there are just a lot of
ways and which one is successful
or not successful, in the worst
case it's just the biggest
learning curve  or you just call it, just get to
know your neighbors, so what an
inspiring invitation to
ask questions or
[applause]
and we also had unanswered
questions, I would like to ask you again in a
show of hands, thank you
very much for such a long time, thank you for your patience
First of all, thank you very much, it's
really really interesting to listen to him,
that you have a really cool discussion here. I
still had a question, even when I
look at the pictures and again about
renewable energies if they are expanded,
I'm a bit worried
that we'll...  to
become dependent on China again and I wanted to
ask you what
strategies we can then develop so
that we don't make the same mistake
we made with Russia,
that we then become incredibly dependent on a country again that
we would
now have in  Shorts also
went straight back to China and it
shows that we
are incredibly dependent on this huge country
and I wanted to ask you,
considering the expansion of the original
energies, what strategies
are there that we can use there  It's better for them to be able to
verify that
the dependency on Russia is
still comparatively small,
so to speak, 70 percent of all
solar modules come from China, 95% from
Asia, so that means we had it
not that long ago, 2007,
so I think 15  Years ago, every
fourth solar cell was made in Germany, so
that means it's relatively
interesting how dramatically quickly
something like this can change. We
then simply eliminated it because
some of the natural processes are somehow
inconvenient, so you have to do them
so often  Respect the environment and then
you have a lot of material and a lot of energy and
we have selected all of that in Germany, we have only left things here
that somehow quickly
make a profit and I think we just need
a general commitment in Germany that
we want to change that
I'm not like that
with Mr. Scholz right now when he's
going to China again, so it's still the same
old way of thinking. If China
attacks Taiwan, the energy transition is over,
you just have to say that
and it's going to get on our feet even more
like the little bit of
gas dependence on Russia, which
is only a good 55%, then we had the
problem that we have. We had a
lot of solar companies setting up
here in Germany in 2019 and they were all
insolvent again three years later
and are now competing on the world market  In order to be able to do that,
I have to
invest a relatively large amount, i.e. I have to build a system
of
at least 5 gigawatts, i.e. I have to invest several
billion euros, and
of course no investor with
the previous history that we have here in
Germany can do that and get out of the dilemma
We only get out if there is a very
clear commitment from politicians
and, above all, what I
would really like to see is cross-party,
so because we now have the
opposition there is somehow
no compass at all, a bit about the
energy transition, so you are worried if  If they turn it back on
then everything will be turned
back again and that is of course poison
for investors, so if I
invest in a solar factory now then I also want it
to make a profit for ten years and that it doesn't meet the
conditions for the solar energy expansion.
Mr. Habeck is making it big and Mr. Merz
bring it down again or something like that,
of course that can't be the case and that's
why we actually need a
round table so that we can
tackle major problems in Germany, climate protection, dependencies or something like that across all parties and not this
small little thing that we're currently seeing
and blocking each other just to
maybe
To add half a percent more to the next election number,
we have to stop that because
we can only solve the big problems in Germany
together and not against each other
and we have to try to
understand that
[applause]
I would like to briefly
add something else, how are many
points agreed?  On one point I would
also warn a little bit
that people now think that
dependency can be reduced by
doing everything nationally at home. I think that would also be the case
if we are now of course discussing
this question of how far
globalization has progressed  Well, it has light and
shadow, I would say yes, but I would
still talk about the pure autonomous
in-house production, even before the keyword
yes, there was a shortage of capital and and a
shortage of labor,
it also has its advantage
if you come from abroad or
with that  with within Europe
and in the world as a whole in its
trade relationship has certainly also for
the topic of
creating global cohesion at all, even
if, as I said, at the moment with
this topic of change through trade and so
on, that under the slogan yes
I think it's just a little bit like what has often been declared as a way, but I
still think it's
wrong that
international relations and
economic relations
can also be maintained, and I
completely agree with that, this one-sided
dependence is the big problem
and there  You actually already had it,
so historically you have already
taken other paths and
recently, I would say, the greed for the
cheap has become so great again that
you have concentrated
on those who offer the cheapest
natural gas from Russia because  That's so cheap,
that has given a huge boost to our entire
economic boom in the last few
decades, yes, and then China as
well as a cheaper manufacturer
of solar panels, for example, and has
put the systems in front of them, which is what the German
systems industry does and also something special
There is still a lot of amateur industry that
still exists in Germany, you always have to say that it's
just the panels themselves that are
manufactured there, a lot of these
things are shifting because it's so
cheap there, so cheap isn't always
cheap  It's just not really
a motto with which we can make
progress here because then we
have to go in the direction of
broadening and diversifying our
sources of supply. We have to think that that
should be the starting point, not
always just Asia, not always just Russia,
but  to be much broader and
there are definitely other regions
in the world plus a stronger
domestic component or a
European component in this whole
production of the things that we
need for the renewable
energy walls, so I think I would
try to expand that a little bit
At this point I would really
like to give our interaction
desk another chance to
be a little more interactive. We
have questions in the audience here all the time.
I have also
seen others, but perhaps Ms. Molltagen
Schnöring still has urgent questions
which we should clarify online, as I said,
there are a lot of questions, some of which are
very detailed, for
example the question of why
the wind farms are not connected to
H2 production plants if the
subway's power is not used so that
hydrogen can
be produced, perhaps it can  Colleague
quaschnik will answer this question but
as I said, many questions
go in a very specific direction
but I think I
learned a lot from these questions alone and I
hope those who have read along here
feel the same way because you
start with them  I'm also thinking about it, so
apologies to everyone if
we can't answer all your questions here right
now, but now that I
have the microphone in my hand,
I'll take the opportunity and maybe say
something again about training Katja
Kaga, we have a course of study at the HTW Berlin
an orientation year with
the Chamber of Crafts so that
young people in particular can see whether
studying or a career in the
skilled trades is right for them and
in this respect universities of applied
sciences perhaps go a
step further than the universities, yes that's
exactly what they do and the hydrogen
question  I don't know, but I'm happy to talk about the
areas with you, so
I mean anyone who has ever
driven past wind turbines on the motorway
has probably been surprised
that when the wind blows, sometimes the
turbines are still standing and that's
simply because we have that in Germany
Electricity is not distributed
sufficiently and simply, systems are also
being switched off, even more perversely at
the moment in the energy crisis,
systems are still being
switched off for economic reasons because the electricity
cannot be marketed so well, so
that's somehow so we
just give electricity away and then
of course there is  The people who say
you could just
put a hydrogen electrolysis next to it
and let the systems continue to run and
produce hydrogen from it and are
the times that the systems
are regulated still manageable, so it's
not half a year or something like that,
but somehow maybe 100,200
Hours and the costs of
hydrogen production come
mainly from the
electrolysers, even if the electricity
is free and if it only
runs for 100 hours a year then the
hydrogen becomes very, very expensive and that is
a bit of the problem with
hydrogen production  If I
have spinny cheaply or
want to have it relatively cheaply, you need a large number
of hours where the systems are running, that does
n't work at the moment and that's why
we probably need
a market launch for hydrogen production in the beginning and funding from the
state because otherwise you just have to  It's
really a long time to wait offshore,
so the systems that are in the North Sea
also have longer
full-time hours and will at some point
supply so much electricity. I ca
n't get them to be transported away from the coast
But
now with some wind turbine in
Brandenburg they probably wo
n't expect it at first and we have to
think about it then it
hurts so if it's a few hours
a year it's not that bad
but if of course then the turbines are
There are individual systems where they
actually stand still for a third of the time
and you would have to think about
how to get such systems onto the market
and it is also a task
for politicians to regulate this because the
technology is actually there but it is
worth it  then it's not and then
it's just not used
then I say thank you very much to those
who asked questions whether here or online that
's really great I sometimes look
at the clock a little furtively because
even if it's as exciting as it is
right now  is who we don't have
that many minutes left, but now I
saw another question right in
the fourth row from here, maybe
we can focus on it again,
yes, I would really like to see maybe two
aspects first, thank you very much for the
interesting discussion  I think it's
really necessary and I also think it's
very effective, but I'm still missing
two aspects, so firstly I
think we don't have enough storage to discuss. I think that's a
huge problem, and you've just
mentioned that with
overproduction that's exactly what happens  is simply
no longer available to us
and heat I think the question of
heat you have now
spoken of heat coupling but that this should
be our future we generate
electricity in order to then generate heat from it again
seems to me to be a very
one-sided approach  so
solar thermal energy why is it talked about so little
and why is it used so
little
okay so then directly on the
technical question then to me exactly so
solar thermal yes it's easy to
differentiate between photovoltaics
which are panels where electricity comes out
and solar thermal energy that is  Simply
collectors, water pipes run through them
and the water is heated directly by the
sun. Both are technically
mature. If you look at the
cost reduction potential,
photovoltaics are simply much better,
so that means we are currently producing
heat if I use
electricity to generate heat from photovoltaics
and the solar thermal energy paripari the
photovoltaics but the costs go
down massively and that's why
the importance of solar thermal energy is decreasing
more and more and solar thermal energy,
like photovoltaics, simply has the problem
that of course in winter when I
need the heat the
least  There is sun and
of course if I heat with electricity I have the
advantage that I can also rely on wind in the winter,
which is then there in
sufficient quantities.
I then only have to save for two to three weeks
but not for half a
year  When it comes to solar thermal energy, there are
solutions where I can completely heat a house with solar thermal energy,
but I just have to
store it in the summer and
take it out again in the winter. I also say
a storage system with a house because
then I have to store really gigantic amounts of
heat storage and that's one  great
concepts that work but they
work on a case-by-case basis and if you do
it across the board we have to
convert all the existing heating systems in 15 years so
I wo
n't be able to fit in large solar thermal systems because of the storage sizes and that's
why it will actually
only be with the heat pump  work where
I then try to store the electricity then
cents on the centrally
and there was the question of which
storage solution I'm trying to
put it very briefly again so it's going to be a
very large one so the storage solution is
not as intensive as they say it is
now this solution and then that's it
Hydrogen will play a role for
long-term storage but hydrogen
is very expensive that's why more efficient solutions will be used for
short-term storage,
for example
batteries, there's a lot going on, we
'll also store with electric cars
so the few
electric cars that do  Those who are currently traveling on German
roads already have a
built-in battery storage capacity
that is larger than all German
pumped storage power storage systems
combined and what they have to do now
and that is technically possible, but
the regulations do not yet mean that
if there is a shortage of electricity you can get out of
it
If you
have 15 million cars, the
battery storage capacity of electric cars,
for example, would be so large that you
could cover all of
Germany's needs for a whole night and
of course these are new
concepts that you can put into practice
So you have to bring them to the road, they have actually
already been developed in the beginning, but you have to
set the framework conditions so that they can be
used and then we will just see
battery storage, electric cars, we will also see
heat storage very
clearly and hydrogen in the combination,
that's what all the calculations
we do show  If we have studies,
the energy can really be secured and
made available for a reasonable price in Germany.
I would now like to ask the
follow-up question: if you now
look at photovoltaics, then there is
always talk of the finite nature of
quartz sand, are there already solutions
for or  Isn't it so finite?
The sand is always a bit of a
question, no, um, of course we'll do that with
the energy transition. That's
the thing. In the end, it's
a battle of materials that we're going to do. No,
that means we have to replace all the cars
through electric cars we have to
cover 2% of the country's area with solar modules, build wind turbines accordingly,
I think that will work.
We have concreted over five percent of the country's area,
which was already a
material battle to build all the roads,
so that means that shows
that we have these quantities  Then we'll be able to
handle things, but of course
we'll also need a lot of raw materials and
have to get them out of the ground and
I just wish that most of the time it
's the case that we do
n't do that in Germany anymore, but
somewhere in another country where people do
n't look so closely anymore  and where it
's particularly cheap and the
standards aren't that high, it's
not just about materials, it's
also food production, so
somehow most of the child labor is in
the chocolate and
no one or hardly anyone looks at it, but we just
have to see that  we can
really get these raw materials with high social
standards and not relocate the problems
we have in Germany
and that is of course
a challenge. I am pleased to see
that we are already discussing such topics in individual points,
for example electric cars,
in the rest
of industrial production  Such
discussions take place very rarely or almost
never at all and we have to look at
the amount of quartz sand is actually there so it's
more for building so it's
that the sand is all
in disrepute in the Arab Emirates, for example,
they have it anyway
Large islands have been piled up in order to
somehow do great things in the sea
and they need special sand that
gets stuck and the desert sand is too
round because of the grains and
some of them have brought sand from Australia to Dubai in order to then
pile up islands where you can  So
somewhere, the
economic system in this world is sometimes
pretty sick, so
I don't think we need jokes like that anymore and
but for the solar modules, I
think we already have
enough materials. Copper could
become more of a problem, so for the
cables what you can do  is not on our
radar at all and what is also a problem
is the time, because there are actually
other
events coming after us and that's why
I actually have to thank you at this point
for this
huge interest in you but also
for  These great answers and
all the inspiration we were able to take with us,
what you don't see at home is
that we have a lot of interested people here
who didn't even get a seat
and still managed to draw attention to us
and that's why I'm happy that there's
so much interest  was for the question of how
do we become independent and climate neutral,
I hope we were able to offer a few solutions
and then I would like to say thank you very much
and see you next time
[applause]